[Music]
everyone gets excited when you're here
but the women really go go crazy what
yes you have female fans as do I that's
those are called sarcastic Woo's yes yes
I have my lady detractors on today I'm
just curious
let's say you're with a lady and it's
sexy Tommy role-playing for lack of a
better term what happens if your music
comes on does your music ever on when
you're say on a date or you're in a
romantic setting does that enhance the
mood or does it sort of on my own iPod
shuffle just for instance like my entire
catalogue just happens to blast on the
speaker you know what if I would that's
what I would have yeah no no it's the
same thing basically if I'm in a
restaurant and somebody who said I lose
my appetite you lose your yeah if you
hear me music yes so basically the same
thing goes yeah it's I I'm so hyper
critical that hearing myself just kind
of makes me well I should've done that
differently or you know so no I I would
prefer LaFontaine be singing yes in my
bedroom
yeah hearing myself yes about me singing
in your bedroom uh yeah you you have a
voice I've heard throughout the year
I do have a voice did you go over that
statement with your lawyer yeah yeah
sure yes what's the least committal way
I can say yeah did your dear fans that
get very intense they ever step over the
line with with their affection does it
ever get maybe a little big well maybe
or dangerous or sometimes they drink at
a show there was one show where I would
sit at the edge of the stage and there
was one lady that was just kind of
sitting underneath and slowly her hand
would like go up my pant leg while I was
singing and she had this terrifying look
on her face it just like how far can I
get ya can I reach the jewels yeah and I
just kind of kept I was singing a very
sweet very serious song and I just kind
of kept like right all I was doing it
one couple came up to me and quite
excitedly said that my voice was he
compared my voice to his wife's vagina
which I don't understand that how is
your voice like that I don't understand
I have no idea but the wife was like his
true though she's in on it and I was
drinking a giant glass of milk at the
time and it was here her vagina and I I
was scared to ask yeah yeah you're all
talk come on security she sold out Radio
City you ready go here we go
the acoustics are incredible
you're a very funny guy you're very
self-effacing you Lisa recently released
you put a post of an album cover of
yours on Twitter that was you said was
you without makeup let's take a look
just cure that's very nice yeah
Hollywood magic yeah yeah don't you
think that if you still had your voice
and that face wouldn't you wouldn't you
still make it in the business I would
have been downgraded from from Hobbit to
troll no I don't know no III think
absolutely not is the answer that
question because I mean as you know I
mean look sir I'm the meat in a hunk
sandwich right now and I like it okay
it's the nicest thing you've said to me
you technically have a voice you have a
voice
you